the one thing that i saw really good to
him uh was when there was the reporting
from the atlantic that trump had called
our fallen heroes our fallen military
men and women suckers and losers it's
the one time i saw a negative story just
um become an obsession of his because it
was just so not true so deeply hurtful
he kept saying over and over again what
kind of monster would do that we had two
dozen sources on the record with their
names on it saying this was not true um
but they ran with the egregious lie
because they were trying to leave away
the military base that is strongly
supportive of trump away from him
what do we do about the press because i
spent more of my time i think talking
about the press
and the mainstream media more than i do
about politics specifically i actually
find that far more interesting it's like
politics sort of is what it is but it's
the filter that's more interesting to me
that because that's what shapes how we
all act and behave and think about all
of it
yeah it fascinates me i think you know
one of i guess my um
deep deep frustrations is the fact you
know i brought accountability from the
podium i obviously had a massive
platform to do it you know cnn msnbc had
to report on the things i was saying
even if they contorted it um but now you
know being in the private sector uh the
megaphone's less and it's easy to you
don't have a republican press secretary
to let go all of these stories that have
been proven false that day in and day
out i told the press so i was blue in
the face no
trump there were not russian bounties on
the heads of troops in afghanistan that
trump ignored no he did not gas and
pummel protesters to take a photo shoot
at the church these things have now been
proven false but there's just virtually
no reporting there's no megaphone like
the white house uh podium to shout that
these narratives are false but i think
the best thing viewers can do is share
with your friends hey no that lafayette
square thing yeah that didn't happen it
wasn't as reported the inspector general
found otherwise the covet lavalier
theory trump was so crazy to proffer in
fact now looks to be true so or at least
pause plausible so you know i think
we've gotta have accountability even in
aftermath and that means all of us using
our tiny megaphones to create a very big
one did any of the lies get to trump i
mean the the very fine people one to me
that's what joe biden used in his
campaign launch video that trump
defended the neo-nazis and it's like no
he literally said i am condemning the
white supremacists and the neo-nazis
when he said find people he meant fine
people on the both sides of the debate
about statues generally speaking did any
of that get to him or he was just like
that's that's what it is
yeah i think you know he's so you said
at this point you know four years and he
was so used to the tired old false
defamatory labels if you're a racist
you're a bigot all of this like he was
used to those narratives i think the
only time that i really saw something
get to him and i'm sure that got to him
in the raw heat of the moment you know
years prior before i came uh but the one
thing that i saw really get to him uh
was when there was the reporting from
the atlantic that trump had called
our fallen heroes our fallen military
men and women suckers and losers it's
the one time i saw a negative story just
um become an obsession of his because it
was just so not true so deeply hurtful
he kept saying over and over again what
kind of monster would do that we had two
dozen sources on the record with their
names on it saying this was not true um
but they ran with the egregious lie
because they were trying to leave away
the military base that is strongly
supportive of trump away from him so you
know his taxes
that rolled off of his shoulder he
didn't care the new york times hit
pieces about his taxes but he did deeply
care about that one in in retrospect now
that he's not president do you guys
think that uh there were mistakes made
along the way or that you could have
done something different in messaging or
anything like that
you know looking back i don't think so
i'm very proud of the work we did sure
you know any time i wish i would have
had more time to uh deal with the
woodward story but i can't help when cnn
dropped something you know i'm someone
who uh the thing that i i like the least
is when i don't have time to prepare i
had the thick binder obviously so you
know i'd spend hours and hours and hours
so when there was a new story you know
you know i'd regret not having extra
time to prepare but no i don't think
anything i said was a mistake i'm very
proud of what we did i'm very proud of
what president trump did how is it for
you being on the other side now i mean
now you're on a daily show for an hour i
go on every couple weeks you get to
fully share your opinions that i assume
you don't have to run by anybody else
and and you're obviously pretty
uncensored as is but just being in now
you're in the media you used to be on
the other side now you're in the media
how's that shift been for you
it's a lot of fun um it is but you know
i guess being in this each and every day
in a different way uh you know i just
watched i sit beside harris faulkner and
i see what an amazing journalist she is
and you've been on with us on
outnumbered and how painstaking she is
and getting her details and her facts
right and i guess it's just um even a
little bit more frustrating to watch how
a good journalist operates and then to
have to report on how the bad journals
operate like uh cuomo if you can call
him that right no you can you can't well
you can use air quotes then you can
they're air quotes exactly but you know
i love it i mean being in the private
sector is a lot of fun i get more time
with my daughter i get to come on
outnumbered with you and podcasts like
this so it's it's a different uh vibe
for sure but a fun one are you uh
enjoying the collapse of cnn the way the
rest of us are i mean you have to talk
about it when i was on outnumbered last
week we talked about it with all the
cuomo nonsense um
it's kind of what they deserve
yeah what's weird is like i was at cnn
for
a year and a half about and it was
during the 2016 election so like i know
these guys pretty well every single
night i sat on the set with um you know
it was anderson cooper usually but i
would go on often to do don lemon i wake
up and do new day with chris cuomo so
it's weird because i knew these guys um
and yeah it's kind of
the um it's your comeuppance if you will
i mean i remember being on with chris
cuomo and a lot of people have forgotten
but we had a rather viral exchange where
he demanded that i call president trump
a liar like demanded it went on for like
20 minutes and then he ended by saying
you've lost all credibility with our
viewers i don't think we can ever have
you back because you won't call trump a
liar and it's just so ironic now to know
that he was lying to his viewers about
using his media contacts but yet he was
this like
this paragon of virtue
shouting down trump campaign personnel
uh because he was so noble and
forthright and honest and clearly that
was not the case yeah
what do you make of just sort of what's
happening broadly on the right right now
like it seems to be there's like it
seems very wide tent to me in some ways
and then there it also feels like well
as we get a little closer to the
midterms and then to 2024 depending on
what trump does it could all be
meaningless whatever we're seeing right
now
yeah look obviously 2022 is the most
important and that will determine i
think a lot of what happens in 2024
because it should be a total
shellacking of democrats next november
and republicans take back the house and
hopefully the senate as well but
assuming that plays out how most people
think it will play out um you know we'll
see if trump decides to throw his name
in the arena he's i think he's gonna be
a very difficult candidate to beat given
that he's got sky-high popularity in the
republican party an incredible track
record you had four successful years um
and you can just contrast that to the
one year biden that's pretty clear but
we have some the great thing we have the
deep bench in our party we have ron
desantis i mean he's the best like
literally the best and
um tim scott's incredible i mean the
list goes on and on we've got such a
deep bench and you compare that to biden
and vice president kamala harris who is
now you know like a madman attacking her
staff verbally and like vastly
incompetent so these two aren't it and
they're looking to pete buddha judge but
outside of this like handful of five
people who do they have they have no one
and we have a really deep bench so we'll
see the voters ultimately decide but
between trump desantis tim scott many
others pompeo a great binge
so i've been asking everybody this but
are you surprised how quickly this thing
got so bad i mean we're only 11 months
into this and supply chain shortages
obviously all the stuff with covid
mandates just you know gas prices
inflation the whole thing like across
the board i just don't know where you
could point to something and be like oh
no it is going well
i have to say i am rather shocked uh you
know and for the first few months of the
biden administration they were trying to
put on this act of the adults are in the
room now rest easy breathe easy we have
brought back politeness
and friendship with our allies and we're
going to be praised by macron of being
back on the world stage and just they
had a lot of people fooled for about
four or five months and then afghanistan
happened and i said at the time
this is a turning point
unmistakably this is a turning point for
this administration and from afghanistan
the polling started to go south and then
everything else started to crumble bit
by bit by bit to the point where today i
see the wall street journal 41 approval
30 among independents so i didn't think
it would get this bad this quick and in
addition to that have voters totally
wake up and say
wow we recognize how bad it is and for
those kind of numbers to be here
in december it just shows you it's not
just the pundits noticing people are
really feeling it at home if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about the media instead of
non-stop yelling check out our media
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out the full episode playlist they're
both right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell